does Chloe Grace Moretz have a tattoo I  do I have a lot of tattoos and they're  all pretty hidden and the only reason I  hide like I have them hidden is because  as an actor you have to spend a lot of  time in hair and makeup if you have  tattoos and as a child actor I saw all  these adults be like don't ever get  tattoos because you're gonna have to  come in at 3am and they're gonna have to  cover your tattoos from like three to  six a.m and then then you'll start  regular hair and makeup I got one on  vacation once there is someone at the at  the hotel we're staying out they're like  we do tattoos we can totally come to  your room uh a horrible idea all I was  gonna get was three dots and it was  first of all the most painful tattoo  I've literally ever had in my life I was  about to cry and me and my stylist who  I've known since I was 11 we did it at  the same time and she and I are both  like at least we did this together  wow it really floated